hello everyone and welcome to this video
tutorial on sub queries in sql by simply
learn
in this video we will learn what is a
sub query
and look at the different types of sub
queries then we learn sub queries with
select statement followed by sub queries
with insert statement
moving further we will learn sub queries
with the update statement and finally we
look at sub queries with delete
statement
all these we will be doing on our mysql
workbench
so before i begin make sure to subscribe
to the simply learn channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
so let's start with what is a sub query
so a sub query is a select query that is
enclosed inside another query
so if i show you this is how
the basic structure of a sub query looks
like so here
whatever is present inside the brackets
is called as the inner query
and whatever is present outside is
called the outer query
so first the inner query gets executed
and the result is returned to the outer
query
and then the outer query operation is
performed
all right now let's see an example so we
have a question at hand
which is to write a sql query to display
department with maximum salary from
employees table
so this is how our employees table looks
like it has the employee id
the employee name age gender we have the
date of join department city and salary
now to solve this query my
sub query would look like this so i'll
first select
the department from my table that is
employees
where i'll use the condition salary
equal to
and then i'll pass in my inner query
which is select
max of salary from employees so what
this does is
it will first return the maximum salary
of the employees in the table
then a router query will get executed
based on the salary
returned from the inner query so here
the output is department sales has the
maximum salary so one of the employees
from the sales department earns the
highest or the maximum salary
if you see in our table the employee is
josef
who earns hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars
all right and joseph is from the sales
department
now let's see how this query works so
here we have another question which is
to find the name of the employee with
maximum salary in the employees table
so this is our previous employees table
that we saw
and to find the employee who has the
maximum salary
my sub query would look something like
this so i'm selecting the employee name
from my table that is employees where i
am using the condition salary equal to
and then i am passing in my sub query or
the inner query
so first i am selecting the maximum
salary this will return
a particular value that is the highest
salary from the table
and if you see our table the highest
salary is hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars
so our query becomes select employee
name from employees with salary equal to
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars so
the employee name is
joseph here and that's the output
now if you want to break it down here
you can see first the inner query gets
executed
so our sql query will first execute the
inner query that is present inside
brackets
select maximum salary from employees the
result is hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars
and then based on the return result our
outer query gets executed
so the query becomes select employee
name from employees where
salary equal to hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars and that
is joseph all right
now we'll learn the different types of
sub queries
so you can write sub queries using
select statement update statement
delete and insert statement we'll
explore each of this with the help of
example on my
mysql workbench so let's learn
sub queries with the select statement so
sub queries are majorly used with the
select statement
and this is how the syntax looks like
you select the column name
from the table name then you have the
where condition followed by the columns
that you want to pass
the operator and inside that you have
this sub query
so here is an example that we will
perform on our mysql workbench
so in this example we want to select all
the employees
who have a salary less than
average salary for all the employees
this is the output so let's do this on
my mysql workbench
all right so let me login to my local
instance
i'll give my password
okay so you can see i'm on my mysql
workbench
so let's start by writing our sub query
using the
select statement
okay so for this demo session we'll be
using a database that is sub queries you
can see it here i have a database called
sub queries
so i'll use this
subquery's database and we'll create a
few tables as well
okay if i run it
now we are inside the subquery's
database
so let me just show you the tables that
are present inside this database i'll
write show tables
if i run it okay there are two tables
employees and employees underscore b
we'll use this table throughout our demo
session
all right now for our select sub query
we want to fetch the employee name the
department and the salary
whose salary is less than the average
salary so we will be using the employees
table so let me first show you
the records and the columns we have in
the employees table
so i'll write select star from employees
and run it okay you can see here we have
20 rows of information
we have the employee name the employee
id age gender
date of joint department city and salary
so this is the same table that we saw in
our slides
okay now for our sub query i'll write
select
i want to choose the employee name the
department and the salary
there should be a comma here instead of
a period
next i'll give my table name that is
employees
where my salary
is less than and after this i'll start
my inner query or the sub query and
write select
average salary so i'm using the avg
function to find the average salary of
all the
employees
from my table that is employees
if i give a semicolon and run this
you'll see the output so we have total
12 employees in the table whose salary
is less than the average salary
now if you want you can check the
average salary
so the average salary is 75 350
now the employees who have a salary less
than the average salary
so these are the people
all right now moving back to our slides
okay now let's see how you can use sub
queries with the insert statement
now the insert statement uses the data
returned from the sub query to insert
into another table
so this is how the syntax looks like so
you write insert into table name
followed by select individual columns so
start from
the table use the where clause and then
you give the
operator followed by the inner query or
the sub query
so here we will explore a table called
products table
we are going to fetch few records from
the products table based on a condition
that is
the selling price of the product should
be greater than
100 dollars so only those records will
fetch and put it in our orders table
all right so we are going to write this
query on my my sequel workbench so let's
do it
i'll give my comment as
update sub query
all right so first of all let's create a
table that is
products so i'll write create table
products then we'll give our column
names the first column would be the
product id of type
integer then we have the column as
item or the product
which is of type worker 30
next we have the selling price of that
product the selling price will be of
type
float and finally we have another
column which is called the product type
and again product type is of the data
type
where car i'll give the size as 30
close the bracket and give a semicolon
now let's just
run it okay so we have successfully
created our products table
now let's insert a few records to our
products table
so i'll write insert into
products followed by
values i'll give
four records the first product id is one
zero one
the product is let's say jewelry
then the selling price is let's say 800
and
the product type is it's a luxury
product
next let's insert one more product
detail
the product id is one zero two the
product
is let's say t showed the price is let's
say hundred dollars
and the product type is non-luxury
[Music]
next i'll just copy this
to reduce our task we'll edit this
the third product's id is 103. the
product is
laptop and let's say the
price is 1300 and
it's a luxury product
i'll paste again and finally i'll enter
my
fourth product which is let's say
table and
the price is 400
and it's a non-luxury product
i'll give a semicolon and we'll insert
these four records to our products table
you can see we have inserted four
records let's just
print it now so i'll write select
star from products
if i run it you can see we have our four
products ready
now we need to create another table
where we are going to
put some records from our products table
so that new table is going to be the
orders table so i'll write create
table orders
now it will have three columns the
order id order id will be of type
integer
then we have product
underscore sold this would be of type
varying character of size 30 and finally
we have the
selling price column
this will be of type float
let's create our orders table
the table name should be orders and
there is some mistake here
okay you should close the brackets okay
let me run it so we have our orders
table ready
now let's write our
insert sub query so i am going to insert
into my table that is
orders and i will select
the product id
comma the item and the selling price or
the sell price
from my table that is products
where i'll write product id
in i'll write my
inner query select prod id
or the product id from
products next
i'll give a where clause where
the selling price is greater than
one thousand dollars so let me tell you
what i am going to do here
i am going to insert into my orders
table the product id
the item name and the selling price from
my products table
where the product id
has this condition so let me first run
this condition
for you which is select prod id from
products where the selling price is
greater than 1000
if i run this okay there is some issue
here
the column name is actually prod id
now let's run it again so that we can
see the product ids of the
products which have a selling price
greater than one thousand so it is one
zero one and one zero three
now let's run the entire query
there is another mistake here let's
debug the mistake
now this should be product id instead of
product underscore in
let's insert again all right so we have
successfully inserted two records to our
table that is orders
now let's see the orders table i'll
write select star from orders
if i run it there you go so there were
two products from our
product table that were jewelry and
laptop which have a selling price
greater than one thousand dollars so the
selling price for jewelry was eighteen
hundred dollars and for laptop it was
thirteen hundred dollars so this is how
you can
use a sub query using the insert
statement
all right now going back to our slides
again
all right now let's see how you can use
sub queries with the update statement
now the sub queries can be used in
conjunction with the update statement
so either single or multiple columns in
a table can be updated
when using a subquery with the update
statement so this is how the basic
syntax of an
update sub query looks like so you write
update table
followed by the table name you set the
column name you give the where operator
and then you write your inner sub query
so we are going to see an example where
we will use this employees table
and using this employees table we will
update the records
of the salaries of the employees by
multiplying it with a factor of 0.35
only for those employees which have age
greater than
27 so we are going to use a new table
called
employees underscore b for this as well
so let's see how to do it
so i'll give my comment as
update sub query
before we see the sub query let's see
what we have in the table
employees underscore b
this is basically a replica of the
employees table
there you go it has the same records
that our employees table has
we are going to use both the employees
table and the employees underscore b
table
to update our records so i'll write
update employees
set salary equal to
let me bring this to the next line
i'll write set salary equal to salary
multiplied by 0.35
where age
in then i'll write select
age from my other table that is
employees underscore b where
age is greater than equal to let's say
27 all right
so let me run through this query and
tell you what we are going to do so i am
going to update the records of the
employees table
specifically for the salary column so i
am checking
if the age is greater than 27 then
we'll multiply the salaries of the
employees with a factor of 0.35
in the employees table let me just run
this
then we'll see our output okay
so it says 18 rows affected which means
there are
total 18 employees in the table out of
the 20 employees
whose age is greater than 27. now if you
see
i'll write select star from
employees you can see the difference in
the salaries
if i scroll to the right you can see
these are the updated salaries
okay now if you check for employees who
have
an age less than or equal to 27
for example markus whose age is 25 his
salary is the same
we haven't updated his salary then if
you see
if you have okay there is one more
employee maya
we haven't updated the salary of maya
because the age is less than
27 all right
now let's go back to our slides again
as you can see we got the same output on
our mysql workbench
now let's explore how you can write sub
queries for the delete statement
now sub queries can again be used in
conjunction with the delete statement
so this is how the basic syntax of a
delete query using sub query would look
like you write delete from the table
name
where clause the operator value followed
by the inner query in within
brackets so here we are going to use the
employees table
and what we are going to do is we will
delete the employees whose age is
greater than equal to 27 so let's see
how you can do it
all right so i'll give my comment
as delete sub query
so we'll follow the syntax that we saw
i'll write delete
from my table name that is employees
i'll write where
age in and then i'll start my
inner query or the sub query i'll write
select
age from
employees underscore b where
age is let's say greater than equal to
32 or let's say the age is less than
equal to 32
close the bracket and i'll give my
semicolon
let me first run the inner query for you
so that you
get an idea of the employees who are
less than
32 years of age so there are nine
employees in the table who have an age
less than equal to 32
so we are going to delete the records if
i run this
okay it says nine records deleted
now let's print or display
what we have in the employees table
if i run this there you go
so if you see the age table we have
total 11 employees now
and all the rages are greater than
32 because we have deleted all those
employees who had an h less than equal
to 32
okay so
let me show you from the beginning what
we did so first we used our
subquery's database then we used our
employees table
so we started by looking at how you can
use the sub query
with a select statement this should be
insert instead
of update so we learned how to
write an insert subquery we use two
tables
products and our orders table
moving ahead we saw how to write sub
queries using
the update command so we updated the
salaries of the employee by a factor of
0.35 for those
who had an each greater than equal to 27
and finally we saw how to use the sub
query using the
delete statement so we deleted all those
records
for the employees whose age was less
than equal to 32
so that brings us to the end of this
video on sub queries in sql
i hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please feel
free to put them in the comments section
we'll be happy to help you thank you for
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here